pour parler des plaintes concernant la
gestion de la crise nous sommes avec
béatrice brugère les secrétaire général
du syndicat unité magistrats snm fo avec
son syndicat elle porte plainte contre x
pour mise en danger de la vie d'autrui
béatrice brugère merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors pour bien
comprendre sur quelle fait votre syndic
est hâtive décidé de porter plainte
alors il faut comprendre que cette
action qui est pas une action anodine
fait pour tirer la sonnette d'alarmé
auprès de notre ministère et surtout
cette action judicaire fit d'abord
l'échec du dialogue social constructif
que nous avons tenté depuis plus de
quinze jours ça vous a pas échappé que
peu de gens et y compris les
journalistes parlent des magistrats et
même si vous voulez l'activité
judiciaire aujourd'hui est relativement
réduite elle continue et on encore des
magistrats des greffiers des personnels
qui travaillent entrer dans ce qu'elle
dans l'écrit ville au juste qu'est ce
que vous dénoncez qu'est-ce que vous
déversez depuis quinze jours
comment j'y viens depuis ils voulaient à
quinze jours depuis le début de la
question de la crise qui a été très
difficile à mettre en place
on a eu des injonctions contradictoires
très fort de rester confinés les deux
quand même continuer à travailler
il me semble tout à fait normal parce
qu'on les a certes la lutte publics
régaliens
mais on a aussi un peu sous-estimé dès
le départ
si vous voulez la protection des
personnels en fait notre ministre nous a
déclaré que les mac était totalement
inutile que les tests ça serait pour la
fin du confinement et que simplement les
gestes barrière suffirait à protéger
justement tous le personnel ces
magistrats qui continue à travailler
dans les juridictions ordonna constater
très vite qui manquait du gel que les
gestes barrière n'était pas suffisant
que la multiplication des d'extraction
judicaire et du personnel policier etc
ne permettait pas partout de respecter
ces gestes barrières béatrice pour
autant effectivement il ya eu des
mesures de réorganisation prise par le
ministère de la justice pense notamment
la simplification des procédures à la
tenue d'audiences en visioconférence par
exemple les audiences à huis clos
malgré ces mesures qui ont été prises
ça vous n'êtes pas satisfaites et vous
portez plainte pour en fait ces mesures
qui ont quand même du temps à être privé
qui voulaient nous sommes totalement
insuffisante parce qu'aujourd'hui on le
voit aussi parce qu'il ya déjà une
inscription
tout le monde commence pas à comprendre
que le port du masque est important et
il n'est pas du tout inutile et non aux
demandes en urgence des têtes pour que
toutes les personnes qui viennent
travailler soit détectée pour pas
contaminer les autres
si vous voulez on demande que les
personnels qu'ils soient encore là et
des matches et qu'on puisse avoir du gel
par tous donc les chiffres nous donnent
raison parc de semaine en semaine nous
allons de plus en plus de contaminer
parmi le personnel judiciaire et il nous
sommes pas du tout entendu sur cette
demande qui nous semble relativement
simple de tester les gens fuient
thématiquement y compris dans les
tensions d'ailleurs exactement la même
chose et donc la démarche est pas du
tout une démarche politique
elle est une démarche de responsabilité
aujourd'hui on n'a plus le temps
d'attendre
il faut absolument que ceux qui sont aux
commandes de l'administration prennent
conscience que ils ont une
responsabilité en tant qu'employeur de
ne pas mettre en danger leur personnel
alors il joue pas à mon prix alors votre
organisation syndicale est minoritaire
chez les magistrats
est ce qu'on peut attendre une réaction
rapide malgré tout est ce que votre
procédure a une chance d'aboutir selon
vous écouter on verra de toute façon on
voit déjà une inflexion depuis deux
trois jours on voit davantage de mac
arrivé alors qu'on nous avait dit qu'on
n'aurait jamais on voit du gel arrive et
outils dans les juridictions donc rien
que pour ça on est déjà extrêmement
content si vous voulez de cette nouvelle
réorientation
évidemment ce n'est pas suffisant je
vous parle même pas des territoires
ultramarins qui sont extrêmement
démunies et qui n'ont pas grand chose
donc si vous voulez ce n'est pas que
symbolique à on verra que ça donne
bien évidemment mais cette action est là
aussi pour intérêt de pointer les
défaillances à ne pas en produire dans
l'avenir on aura d'autres crises c'est
évident et il faut absolument prendre
conscience qu'une gestion de crise ne
peut pas le faire au doigt mouillé et
qu'il faut rien entendre les acteurs du
terrain alors il ya une nouvelle plainte
qui a été également déposée contre
messieurs castaner nunez et philippe
pour mise en danger délibérée de la vie
d'autrui elle a été déposé par le
syndicat policier vigie est ce qu'il ne
fallait pas attendre au moins la fin de
l'épidémie pour enclencher des
procédures judiciaires
alors d'abord nous on n'a pas pu déposer
plainte contre contre quelqu'un de faire
on a on n'est pas du tout dans cette
logique là on cherche pas à avoir des
fonctions faire tomber quelqu'un ce
n'est pas du tout notre démarche dont
les très constructif moi je on se croit
qu'au contraire c'est maintenant qu'il
faut agir parce que à la fin du
confinement on comptera peut-être les
morts ou les gens qui ont été en grande
difficulté or c'est aujourd'hui qu'il
faut prendre les mesures le discours de
l'union nationale n'a pas de temps petit
on n'écoute pas les acteurs du terrain
qui vident
attention là il ya une vraie possibilité
de mise en danger et on demande à notre
administration de nous protéger il ne
faut pas oublier que au contraire ce
temps est extrêmement précieux on n'est
pas là pour faire le bilan après devoir
il n'a pas été fait ou pas sont pas bien
faites pas ça l'idée c'est que tout de
suite une prise de conscience que nous
avons besoin de davantage de protections
et surtout ils comparent oublier que
nous sommes amis père régaliens la
justice est un pilier comme les hôpitaux
comme l'armée comme la colline il faut
absolument protéger nos agents parce que
nous avons une obligation d'assurer un
service public
merci de manche voilà si demain tout
l'équipement au travail pour contaminer
on aura plus personne
merci beaucoup béatrice brugère d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes secrétaire général du syndicat
unité magistrats snm
fo fois